it's not shown on maps of the world or even on
small maps of the United States but a traveller
driving along the coast of Connecticut is certain
to come to Milford a community of 18,000 people
Milford is prettier than some towns and
older than most but the important thing
about Milford is not its age or how
it looks but that as a community a
place where people live and work it is like
other communities all over the United States
the story of how Milford began
how it grew and what its people
do every day is much the same as
that of thousands of other towns
early morning in milk would find some
people already at work what they are
doing will be helpful to others when the
rest of the town wakes up and then when
the others get up they are soon busy with
their own affairs Phil for instance must
take to school the model he built at the
post office it's for a class project in
geography as usual his mother was seeing to
it that her family has a good breakfast and
Phil's dead glances at the morning paper
before leaving for his office right on the
front page there's a story telling about the
study of Milford to be made by Phil's class
this reminds them that Phil ought to
be dressed by now so that he can start
for school on time his mother agrees that
he's done a splendid job but she wonders
if he's forgotten that his first class
will be starting in only a few minutes
traffic is heavy in the morning when
so many people are driving to work
or to the shopping center of course
the policeman has no way of knowing
that Phil is in a hurry his job is to keep
traffic moving so that no one will be late
after talking the whole thing over the class
decides that the best way to study Milford is
to divide into small groups and have each group
take pictures and make notes about a different
part of community life even though everyone wants
to start right away it's better to delay a few
minutes and first learn how Milford began and why
its particular location was chosen a little more
than 300 years ago there were woods and meadows
where Milford now stands a traveller passing
along the old road to Boston saw that the land
would be good for farming and for raising cattle
and the Weber world River would provide water
for the livestock as well as a hub of a fishing
boats and sailing vessels so almost 150 years
before the declaration of independence a few
families moved here to start a new community
they cleared the woods laid out farms built
cabins and protected themselves from Indians by a
stockade the first public building in Milford was
the meeting house where the settlers worshiped
then came the water meal where grain was ground
in the meal and flour as the town grew places
were needed for the blacksmith the carpenter the
Tanner and a store keeper when the Indians became
more friendly other families moved to Milford and
settled outside the stockade the paths between
the houses became roads most American roads were
made by neighbors visiting each other's homes
with the discovery of the steam engine small
factories were built and then a railroad line the
town continued to grow slowly changing quietly
with the times until it became the milford we
know today it is modern milford that the class
will study by finding out what its people doon
by seeing how the work of one man helps others
they will learn the real meaning of the word
community and understand what the community means
to them Margaret and her group take a bus to the
airport the bosses which carry people all around
Milford also run to make ringtones it isn't
far from the center of Milford to the airport
the pilot of the helicopter is Margaret's
brother and he's going to take her up high
over the town so that she can see it all at one
time and with her camera Margaret will be able
to show the rest of the class but Milford looks
like from the air the boys remind her to look
for the river and the harbor and to notice how
the buildings and factories were built near them
airports have their own safety
regulations when the runway is
clear the pilot will receive a signal to takeoff
Margaret's brother has been flying planes at
the airport for three years and knows what his
sister wants to see from the air it's easier
to understand what the teacher means when she
says a community is a center of living where
people depend on each other on the outskirts
of farms which produce food for the people
in Milford and in the cities and towns nearby
the powerhouse is on the river
because it is easier and cheaper
to have boats bring the heavy loads
of coal in which electricity is made
now there is the town itself with its
rows of neat houses wide streets and
its business buildings at the center
of town square in the middle is the
Town Hall with the offices of the people
who carry on the government of Milford
railroads are important to Milford as
they are to all communities travelers
go on fast trains to Boston and New York
into cities far beyond businessmen and
farmers use the railroad to ship the
products they don't sell in Milford
from the Milford freight station good start
their journeys to points everywhere and
shipments arrived here from all over the world
a second group came to the station with a dairy
farmer who is picking up a shipment of new
milk bottles he will take the children home
with him to finish their assignment over the
roads that crisscross through Milford a car
can go from the station near the center of town
to a farm several miles away in a few minutes
the farmers nephew Bobby's also a
member of the geography class and
has arranged to show the others what
happens on his uncle's dairy farm
these cars are well fed and raised
scientifically it's nice to have
cars that a friendly body tells them but the
really important thing is to have cows that
give a large amount of rich milk on all dairy
farms paying time is the busiest season of
the year dick who lives in town and seldom
visits farms doesn't want to miss a thing
the grass was cut three days ago and left in
the fields to dry it's important now to get
it into the barns before a summer char can
spoil the new hay a baling machine gathers
the hay compresses it into bundles and binds
it all in one operation with such machinery
one farmer can do as much as eight men working
by hand he can use the time saved by machinery
to cultivate other crops like apples peaches
corn potatoes and garden vegetables a farmer's
life is one job after another the next is to
pick up a load of bricks to fix the chimney
the Brickyard is only a few miles away and
close to the clay pits brick-making is an
industry that was developed through one
of Milford's natural resources for bricks
are made by mixing sand and water with a
clay from the pits these bricks are not
only used for buildings in Milford a bear
exchanged for the products of other areas
a truck takes the clay to the molding machine
where it will be stamped into the familiar
blocks these must then be put on drying racks
because bricks must dry in the Sun for a long
time before they can be hardened by baking
brick making depends on the weather in the
changeable climate of Connecticut the plant
can operate only during the warm months of
the year and is shut down entirely in winter
time loading and unloading the conveyor belts
is done by hand but the rest of the operation
proceeds mechanically the machines do the work
of many hands and enable a small crew of men
to turn out half a million bricks each week
300 years ago a farmer probably would have brought
the milk and butter he produced to give to the
brick maker in exchange today the farmer pays cash
for the bricks he is taking away when goods are
exchanged or paid for that's called trade trade
is an important community function whether it
happens in a Brickyard a grocery store or anyplace
else since Ann's family does not have a farm they
purchase food with money nowadays exchanging
goods is made easier by the use of money which
represents either the value of goods things people
make or the value of services things people do in
the shopping center of Milford and mother can buy
the produce of farmers the farmers in turn with
the money they get from the sale of their crops
can buy things made in Milford of Goods brought
into Milford to be sold materials needed on the
farm or in the dairy they can buy clothes for
each member of the family services like goods can
be bought with money the baker supplies goods with
doctors dentists and lawyers supply services the
man who shines and repairs shoes sells a service
although a newspaper costs only a few pennies
it provides an important community service it
is a form of communication but it brings to
the citizens of Milford news of what's going
on in the world and advertisements tell what
merchants have for sale to report on how a
newspaper is published is the assignment of Billy
and Tom who usually deliver papers after school
printing a modern newspaper is a complicated
process involving not only the gathering of
news to be printed but the use of many machines
by men who have learned how to operate them
the boys have seen this print shop many times
before but a fall of it only is a place to pick
up their papers now as a result of what they've
been hearing at school they see how important
it is to get the papers to their customers
on time so that people are kept interested
in both the community and the affairs of
the world as part of their project Tom and
Billy are going to report on all the community
services they see as they deliver their papers
Billy's route includes the courthouse
where the courtroom the police station
and the jail are located in every community
laws must be enforced in order to protect
all citizens against the harm that a few
individuals might do and it's customary for
the judge to conduct the trial with dignity
and he must see that everyone concerned has
a fair hearing in court today is a motorist
who was arrested for speeding he is charged
with endangering the lives of other citizens
Billy stays on and long enough to make notes
for his report then he continues his rounds past
the post office and around the village green
he crosses Memorial Bridge which honors the
first settlers who picked this place to start
the community and then pedals into the part
of town where he and his schoolmates live
suddenly he sees something he didn't expect
mr. Young's barn is on fire Billy knows where
the fire alarm box is located this is the
quickest and surest way to call for help
the fire department is for the safety and
protection of everyone in the community
nothing is more important than to get the men
and equipment to the fire as quickly as possible
as part of the town's safety
service police officers must
clear the streets for a fire department
hydrants to provide water for the firemen when
they need it have been placed all over town the
cost of the water system like the fire and police
departments is shared by everyone in the community
thanks to the early alarm the blaze is put
out before it can do much damage the chief
is grateful for billy's alertness and Billy
is pleased to have such a good item for his
report he saw the third man protecting
the citizens in the community of Milford
back in the classroom each group tells a
different part of the story of the town
and these fit together into a complete picture
of Milford this story becomes a motion picture
and in it they can all see what each
group has learned about the community
the film makes clear the meaning of what
the class is found it shows how Milford
growing out of the countryside around it
now serves at the center of the region it
is linked with other similar centres by
various means of transportation in the
air and on the ground on the outskirts
of Milford in almost all directions are
farms which produce vegetables and fruit and
dairy products for the people in town and in
its earth is a natural resource clay which
supplies the raw material for brick making
one of the several manufacturing industries of
the area in the community are many conveniences
and services which the people of the town as
individuals could never provide for themselves
through these organised services a
single person can help many others
by means of trade it is possible
to exchange all these goods and
services to make life for everyone more
comfortable and to suit the tastes of all
that's what the geography class has learned
about Milford and the story is much the same
for all communities from big cities to small
country villages everywhere in the world a
community is started and grows because people
need a place in which to live and to work a
place to do the things for one another
which will make it possible for all to
have a better life the geography class has
learned the importance of the community and
each knows and understands the part he must
take in the life of the community all over
the world people belong to a community
and communities belong to their people